what we have here
are 25 minutes of mostly uninterrupted
cyberpunk 2077 gameplay
before we get started if you don't want
any early game spoilers i recommend
clicking out now with that out of the
way these first three scenes show
snippets from each life path you can
pick at the beginning of the game
this first one we are going to take a
look at is from the street kid path
in this scenario v was born in night
city and is in the middle of hijacking a
car when an
unfriendly jackie wells shows up your
moment to shine
kiddo good luck
[Music]
let's take this piece of wondertech for
a whirl
you're a man of little faith see
we're rich now fire up and call me when
you're underway
tell you where to go
hmm looks like this will be a cool
breeze
[Music]
[Music]
okay easy
nothing personal go by just biz
rayfield's mine what man never heard of
thieves honor
finders keepers i was first listen
only one or two ways to do this friendly
or [ __ ] up either way the ending's the
same
i'm taking the car what what are you
doing
[Music]
you're under arrest
and where i can see him nice and slow
jackie wells my old pal from the hood
see you haven't grown an ounce wiser hey
detective stance been a while huh
inspectors
same [ __ ]
speaking of your mug's familiar too
yeah you're saying to me
left for atlanta looking for a slice of
happiness
guess you didn't find it i've always
maintained it's the same for all you
termites in haywood born here
live here die here looks like i was
right
you know [ __ ] all about me
truth hurts huh just watch your tone
i'm not a patient man hey come on stance
give us a break huh you lock us up
let's just jerk off till trial and then
what
worst case we get some months
you know standing room only nowadays in
alberta
so i'd probably be out early
ah the easter thieves 433 trash
got him in custody mr fujioka we'll be
taking them now
it's a waste of effort i have no time to
testify or play it under investigation
we let them go sir i suggest you toss
them in the sea
[Music]
cuff legs broken so this trash doesn't
float
you heard him [ __ ]
next up we have the nomad life path and
this setup v
is trying to smuggle something into
night city with the help of jackie we
have two sections from this introduction
v repairing a car envy and jackie
speeding across the border into night
city with border control hot on their
tail
you said it was nothing serious when i
came in you said you were sure
guess i was wrong can i always look for
another shop where they won't ask a low
nomad why he's hugging the border
that's fine step aside what
got any idea what to do
i'm going to bypass the coupling and rig
a hotline
compressor will run on and on
did anyone ask your opinion
okay let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you
not shabby at all questions how long
it'll last you
and it'll get me to night city i'll
figure something else out there
[Music]
antenna on this heap don't seem like it
packs a punch not liable to hear much
you don't say
hey mike didn't know you had a customer
uh rolled in a few hours passed i
i thought he'd at least called in don't
you swear to mine
we're gonna hash it out
don't you know you owe the sheriff a
word when you pay his town a visit
to tell him what's brought you here
maybe even over a cup of coffee
no need to worry i won't be staying long
didn't answer my question now did you
[Music]
you're gonna tell me what happened back
there
let's say i have a bad feeling about
this oh
happened a lot to you rarely
smelling trouble around the bend drive
jackie just drive
someone's coming our way this does not
look good
stop your vehicle immediately let's get
out of here on it
you are transporting contraband that is
corporate property
i repeat stop the car
dinner
gotta keep moving
finally we have the corpo life path and
this scene v is a successful corpo
meeting an old friend named one jackie
wells
[Music]
no designated landing site has been
detected at the destination
find a spot close to the bar as close as
you can
[ __ ] procedures initiating landing
sequence based on new parameters
thank you
we have arrived at your destination
[ __ ] your problem psycho suit this
look like a landing pad to you
could have [ __ ] crushed us
keep an eye on the av for me will you
i don't get paid to do that i wasn't
asking
i'm not a scratch on it when i get back
welcome to lizzy's
[Music]
machines
[Music]
now come here often do you it's good to
see you
now sit down and tell me what's got your
shorts in the knot
it's good to see you too jack how you
been
moving away from the opening setups this
section will show you the ins and outs
of brain dance or bd
a virtual reality tech that lets v
examine past events
in gritty detail and remember everything
on
full blast they'll spot us extra for a
wicked adrenaline
okay on you go
down everybody on the ground i want to
see you kissing the flooring
money now or i will [ __ ] drop you i
swear to god
well yeah hey now before i blow your
[ __ ] head off
[Music]
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well that was
too much felt
could feel the guy's pain his stress his
hope hope wrapped up in something else
probably took a booster just before
you'll be fine
got everything set up let's switch over
to editing mode
i'll sever the link to the bd roller
sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely the
whole scene's yours
full cam control and analysis mode so
move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox
so analysis mode you control playback
can even pause when you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
snatch the cash get out and we sell the
bd to those psycho freaks from the
studio
got it got it cream is hell right well
that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like
give it a try rewind roll it back to the
top
all good neat now try fast forwarding a
bit
plan simple do nothing
okay you can also reset the recording
that'll take you right back to the
beginning
try it
now for some fun this here's why you
came in the first place
in analysis mode you get to view and
even scan
details of the enviro recorded by the bd
roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy at the beginning
now scan it
plant simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
snatch the cash get upset
okay right here
excellent let's move on
now heads up in analysis mode you can
ferret out background noise and
conversations if the roller got close
enough
this tech records everything every
little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
go ahead and try that now okay good
now you should see several sound
signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it
pack a six case of broseph and a couple
of zappers
okay we have a deal today on two flavors
cuddy and surfing everybody so
any thoughts unbelievable
seriously like what's happening right
next to me
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up
everything all the elements in the
background then an editor tweaks
makes them pop keep playing with the
sound explore it a bit
we'll move on when you get bored
what i see you kissing the flooring
money
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what eb's got kiroshi optics that
grab
infrared meaning you should be able to
grab heat signatures from her recording
hello nice scanning works on peeps too
walk up to the wounded chick try
scanning her
alright next thing scroll forward to the
part where our artist gets a lead
injection
where i will [ __ ] drop you i swear
not well
no [ __ ] head off
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming
but you will here it comes my favorite
part of the game
see the blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam
must have caught our shooter you'll see
in a sec
cam feeds to the screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screens in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
his own chumba shot probably plan to all
along
must have got a nice slice of cred on
the black market for a bd like this
bd freaks are ready to pay a prime for a
real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
next up is a bit of combat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's just a matter of time [ __ ]
hey she's there
please take [ __ ] steak
so this is
[Music]
ah
do not do this invitations against my
police
please i do not want them
calm down it's over now i'm not with
them
now here's a bit of hand-to-hand combat
with a pair of interesting characters
i know where i'm gonna strike before i
do it
typical knew i'd say that you're for a
fight
which one of you is my guy me
i wasn't expecting the tag team but
whatever i guess
so who do i got first no no
you don't get it that body and this one
i'm the same person so
what i'm seeing double i used to be
twins
which you could probably guess the twins
had a close bond
they wanted to be closer stronger
so they installed neural oscillation
sticks and now they're
well me one
my bodies do everything together
everything
fine but we're raising the stakes
fair see no problem with that so
can we get started show me what you got
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
and last but not least here's v and
jackie blowing off steam in a nightclub
called
afterlife
foreign
yeah about time holmes
what's new with senora wells
uh you know she's worried about me
whatever can't help herself you know
checking to see if i'm not riding in
some dumpster like most of the whales
boys
it's really starting to wear on me more
i tell her everything's okay
the more i feel like i'm straight up
lying
but that's done after tomorrow
afterlife here we go baby
yeah we're only here because dex is
pulling the strings
doubt that puts us in the same league as
them
oh but we are they just don't know it
yet
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
place used to be a morgue believe that
who would have thunk i know right
way before our time that when proper
burials were still a thing
and who might you clowns be
name's v this is jackie wells
oh is that supposed to sound familiar
it will soon we're here to see dex
yo dex got two live ones saying they're
here to see you
yeah all right then
says he needs a second or two go get
yourselves drinks or something
way ahead
this is it heart of night city
let's see right there beating hear it
can you imagine susan forrest boa boa
maybe even morgan blackhand all sat on
those stools
fell asleep on that same bar looks like
we're up
hey you see that old lady there
that's rogue best fixer in all of night
city
thought dex was the best
rogue was lining up jobs when dex was
still [ __ ] in diapers
the place belongs to her what can i get
you
you order two to kilo fashions with a
splash of zeressa and a chili garnish
duo of johnny silverhands coming up
right on chica
somebody did their homework looks like
the dog ate mine
age old tradition drinks are named after
our regulars
say i wanted a drink named after me what
would i have to do
snuff it mind-blowingly spectacular
fashion
it would be best ah what a beautiful
tradition
tonight's city and the afterlife
[Music]
[Music]
you made it you blown up all over the
news are you alone
i just want the money you got the chip
all right start her up bug
why don't you go to the bathroom wash up
we going to be with you in a minute
oh come on man your neck it's a mess
while hot security has yet to comment we
do know the suspect seems to have quiet
initiating combat mode go destination
confirmed
that's what i'm talking about all right
in and out
[ __ ] we're rich oh we are going to
the major leagues charity
jack oh [ __ ]
no no no no no no okay get to a clinic
now mr l's condition
is critical immediately just hold on
hey hey just think about all the good
[ __ ] we're gonna have huh
oh sorry
[Music]
take the [ __ ] chip decks
every corporal cop in this city is gonna
be blasting down these doors
after what you and your psycho friend
did
we didn't need all this cock-sucking
attention dammit
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wake the [ __ ] up samurai
we have a city to burn
i love this town a city of endless
opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
city like any other it's bigger
no mana not just any other city legends
are born here
the major leagues we're only here
because dex is pulling the strings
doubt that puts us in the same league as
them but we are
they just don't know it yet but if you
got the gohanis
and you know how to use them you can do
damn near anything
unless you catch a bull even then you go
out with a bang right
you know you can make heaps more eddies
as a motivational speaker
yo mr v a pleasure so what's the gate
dicks you meant to come out in one piece
[Music]
how about we go over the plan there's
this
prototype tech a biochip to be precise
jobs to grab it guessing it belongs to a
court arasaka
we are robbing some heavy hitters
thought you could blackmail me
[ __ ] high risk have a war first rule
of the afterlife
baby goes without saying we do this on
the hush
ideally no bodies not a one
sounds simple enough these lead [ __ ]
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
miami we're
movement bulletproof what the [ __ ] just
happened in there i can't stop digging
night city
[ __ ] happy now jackie yeah
that's [ __ ] high oh my god we're so
[ __ ]
[Music]
six what the [ __ ] game is give me
and you who are you
[ __ ]
i wouldn't write these lyrics for myself
[Music]
so it's kind of interesting to to get
into like the mindset of
who is this character and what would
they write about what
what's their agenda
[Music]
it's interesting to to try to like catch
a language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
part of this game
[Applause]
there's a reason why we're here
it was piotr maybe who was a fan of the
band
he knew refused and he knew my voice and
he said oh that's a perfect voice for
for johnny
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when johnny is supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy gonna
drag a corporal rat on stage
make them kneel down with gaston light
them up so of course there are things
that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this rebel
that's fighting against like the the
corporals and
that's definitely something that's been
a part of my life and a part of refused
we came out of the punk rock scene of
northern sweden
he's like the future version of us
[Music]
so i i think it makes sense i think it
totally makes sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him you know so it's pretty cool
yeah no no no no trails
but yeah but like white vibrato
[Applause]
we don't have a different mode than just
going all in
so we really work on these songs trying
to make them as good as possible but
then
they're not actually our songs it's
interesting as
as a musician to play another musician
because that's essentially what we're
doing i mean we're not here
as refused we're here samurai and i'm
here with johnny
it's still around you know so it's like
the voice we're representing here is
someone else
it's been a mind [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you
[Music]
i mean the shouting in itself is just
like second nature to me because i've
been i've been doing this for a very
long time
but then when someone comes in and says
i'm happy with everything except for as
a limb
again it's as a as a okay
okay the shouting is great but think of
that accent so think of that like
enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very different way of singing
when you're screaming like that and it's
hard to sort of swallowing some
syllables there adjust your accent oh
yeah just try it again
so it's been a bit frustrating
it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't horrible but it wasn't great
but i mean i get it i mean we
we have to maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is me
like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know you think the things like the
rhythm and you think about the pitch and
you think about all these things but
then someone comes in and like
that word sounded weird i'm like what no
it's how i sing but so it's been a very
uh yeah pretty painful
at times it's all right see it is soon
i'm chipping in
roll the boots out chip in here
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of
as a person that's not a gamer i don't
think i fully understand the impact that
this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
then that's going to be great i mean we
are spending a lot of time
trying to get this right trying to get
it to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting it's a very
different way of
of making music actually
johnny silverhand is the zac de la rocha
of the cyberpunk universe a musician
with a radical anti-establishment
message
johnny's a disgruntled veteran of the
1990s central american conflict an
anarchist and
most importantly the first rocker boy
here's the origins and rise to fame of
one of cyberpunk's most prolific
[Music]
characters
a rocker boy is a class wholly unique to
creator mike pondsmith's cyberpunk
universe
rocker boys and gals are charismatic
public figures
who speak up against the powers that be
they usually come in the form of
musicians like johnny silverhand but
they don't have to shred the guitar or
play an instrument to be considered a
rocker boy
according to pondsmith himself to be a
rockerboy you just need to be able to
eloquently stick it to the man and
convince your buds to stick it to the
man with you
man but a rocket boy doesn't have to be
a musician a rocker boy
can be anyone who's a orator of the
people
anybody who can talk to others
and convince them by the power of words
music sometimes art and so forth
although johnny silverhand is a 100 year
old rock legend in cyberpunk 2077 his
story begins in the 1990s during the
central american conflict a bloody
struggle launched by the united states
war machine to squash
communism unsurprisingly the united
states had ulterior motives
there were important resources at play
that the united states government wanted
a piece of
while the us did a good job of keeping
this a secret from the general
population
soldiers began to uncover the
government's underhanded intentions
many enlisted soldiers broken and
battered at this point deserted and
returned to the united states
among these deserters was one robert
john under
after losing an arm he returned to night
city with a red-hot rebellious spark in
his
eyes after getting fitted with a new
arasaka design
cybernetic arm he changed his name to
johnny silverhand and formed a band
called
samurai the group consisted of carrie
eurodyne denny best isis formerly known
as nancy and henry
you know good old henry samurai's music
was a global phenomenon the world knew
who johnny silverhand was
and they heard his messages of rebellion
and revolution
loud and clear samurai criticized
government world leaders
and of course the mega corporations that
ruled the world
more importantly samurai's music lit a
fire under the general public
everyday folks were picking up
instruments and getting their message
out there
and so the rocker boy was born
unfortunately samurai came to an abrupt
end when nancy pushed her abusive
boyfriend out of a window
and killed him i say good for nancy but
the united states justice system
seemed to disagree and put her behind
bars shortly after samurai separated
johnny silverhand kicked off his solo
career
his first solo release was titled sins
of your brothers
if his work with samurai consisted of
vague lessons in rebellion
sins of your brothers overtly called out
the injustices of the central american
conflict
johnny's first solo album proved to be a
massive hit
not only did it sell like crazy but it
changed the world's perception of the
central american conflict and
shined a light on the united states
imperialistic practices
things were going well for johnny his
fame was on the rise and he started
seeing a woman named alteria cunningham
or alt for short
alt an incredibly talented netrunner
created a program called soulkiller that
essentially rips a netrunner's mind from
their skull
and makes a copy of it inside a
mainframe the body still alive is left
to decay
the good times sputtered to a halt when
arasaka thugs kidnapped all to get a
hold of her soul killer program
johnny in a fit of rage devised a plan
to rescue alt from the arasaka building
with the help of thompson a famous
journalist
with a distaste for mega corpse it's
important to note that at this point
johnny hates arasaka he already did to
some extent but now things
are personal i imagine he'll make his
hatred of arasaka
very clear in cyberpunk 2077.
i'm sure he also hates that shiny metal
arasaka arm he's rocking
with the help of his former bandmates
johnny silverhand puts on a free show
near the arasaka building to hopefully
incite a riot
then johnny would lead an assault on
arasaka to save alt
just like when rage against the machine
performed at the democratic national
convention in 2000 a riot erupted
outside of the arasaka building
after samurai played a song titled chip
and in fun fact swedish hardcore band
refused did an official rendition of
this song which you can listen to right
now
as well as a few other samurai songs
johnny's crew with a crowd of 6000 broke
into arasaka headquarters
sadly they were too late alt was dead
and her mind was trapped in a mainframe
this particular section comes from a
story titled never fade away in the
cyberpunk
2020 rulebook we will most likely visit
this event in another video but if you
want a more in-depth look at this key
moment in johnny's life we recommend
reading the full story
after that johnny disappeared there were
rumors that the indomitable cyborg adam
smasher put a bullet in johnny but his
remains were never found
of course this isn't the last time we'll
hear from johnny silverhand as his
electronic ghost seems to play a
significant role in cyberpunk 2077
played by the illustrious keanu reeves
cyberpunk
there's a brief overview of johnny
silverhand's life and legacy
there's a lot more to this story but
we'll have to wait until november to
find out more
in the meantime if there's a cyberpunk
topic you'd like to see us cover leave
it in the comment sections below
and make sure to tune in next week as
jean-luc breaks down johnny's arch
nemesis
arasaka and with that we'll see you next
time samurai
one of the oldest and most influential
mega corporations in the world of
cyberpunk is arasaka
it has played a pivotal part in some of
the franchise's most important stories
and is set to be a major player in
cyberpunk 2077.
in many ways it's looking like arasaka's
role in the game is said to be the
culmination of characters
and plot lines the pen and paper game
has been building for decades
so before we see it play out in the
video game you need to know the history
of arasaka
who its major players are and how this
simple manufacturing company became a
trojan horse
for world domination
[Music]
the now monolithic arasaka started out
as a simple japanese manufacturing
company
it was founded around the turn of the
20th century by sasai arasaka
a clever businessman with a talent for
predicting the direction the world was
going
he saw world war ii on the horizon and
positioned his company as a major
military manufacturer for japan
bringing him a lot of success sasai also
had the foresight to see that japan
would lose
so arasaka began distributing its vast
wealth to overseas accounts
sparing itself from the ruin of the
japanese economy following the country's
surrender in the years following the war
arasaka would slowly trickle those funds
back in
keeping the company on top as a vital
part of japan
that's how arasaka got its start but the
history of the modern day arasaka begins
with sasai's son
saburo saburo arasaka was a renowned
pilot during world war
ii he was fiercely nationalistic
strongly believing that japan should
take its rightful place as leader of the
world
japan surrender at the end of world war
ii was a huge blow for saburo
who contemplated suicide but like his
father he had the vision and foresight
to think ahead
saburo saw the global economic path the
world was taking
and knew that while japan had failed
militarily it could succeed commercially
thanks to his father's actions arasaka
continued to thrive
and accrue a massive fortune after the
war so
saburo prepared and waited until his
father's death in 1960
when he assumed control of arasaka it
was then time for saburo to start the
long game
his end goal to bring back japan to
imperial glory
and become a political and economic
superpower that controlled the
world saburo's first step was to create
and expand the arasaka bank
the bank acted as the reliable backbone
of the company
always providing good income thanks to
smart business decisions on saburo's end
this allowed arasaka the freedom to
invest in other ventures
such as the arasaka security division
which provided the highest standards of
electronic security
as well as physical manpower like armed
guards by the 1990s arasaka's security
was
the most powerful and respected security
company in the world
with thousands of businesses using their
services
and then the collapse happened ever the
forward thinker
saburo saw the economic crash coming and
made preparations
as well as a few manipulations in order
to profit from the destruction of modern
society
arasaka came out of the collapse as one
of the largest corporations in the world
and it was time for saburo's master plan
to take shape
arasaka's security would create one of
the first corporate armies
saburo would go on a spree buying out
valuable businesses with arasaka bank in
one hand
and eviscerating the competition with
his personal army with the other
by 2020 the mantle of ceo pastor
saburo's eldest son
k arasaka but in many ways kay was just
a figurehead and the true power in
decision making
still lay with a 101 year old sabura his
mind was still as sharp as ever and his
goal of complete world domination was
ever present
the only thing keeping him from
achieving it was alliances made by
other corporations in the interest of
keeping arasaka in check
one such corporation was militech an
american arms manufacturer and military
contractor
militech was arasaka's biggest
competitor and this rivalry would end up
being the source
of arasaka's first major defeat
what would later be known as the fourth
corporate war started in 2021
as a simple rivalry between ceno and
otec which were fighting over the assets
of the recently bankrupt ihak
looking to gain the upper hand both
turned to the backing of large megacorps
for military resources
otech went with militech and ceno went
with arasaka
the two mega corps had been at each
other's throats for years
and this was the perfect excuse they had
been looking for to begin a proxy war
where they could battle it out
and like many proxy wars it stopped
being about a dispute over a bankrupt
company's assets
in fact by 2022 ceno and otec had
settled their little war
but arasaka and militech were just
getting started and tensions quickly
escalated into a very
real war many organizations and
countries around the globe were dragged
into their conflict
including the united states and japan
both of whose economies heavily relied
on militech and arasaka respectively
things were spiraling out of control
quickly as this corporate rivalry was
setting the world on fire
eventually arasaka began losing ground
in the united states
with its final major holdout being night
city home of its american headquarters
this all led to one of the most
important moments in the world of
cyberpunk
militech sent several strike teams of
mercenaries to infiltrate arasaka tower
one of which was led by the legendary
johnny silverhand
you can learn more about why johnny was
involved in our video about him
there's a lot that happened in arasaka
tower that day enough to do a whole
video on it alone
but the most important thing is how it
ended
a thermonuclear device was detonated
resulting in the destruction of central
night city
and the deaths of over half a million
people in what would later be referred
to as the night city holocaust
the blame was placed on arasaka and u.s
president elizabeth cress used the event
to nationalize militech
and expel arasaka from the united states
small conflicts continued for two more
years
but at this point arasaka had lost ceo k
arasaka eldest son of saburo died by
suicide in 2025
officially bringing the fourth corporate
war to an end
the fallout of the war severely damaged
arasaka
all its overseas assets had been seized
by different governments
and it was kicked out of pretty much
everywhere the japanese government which
had long butted heads with arasaka
was terrified of a potential retaliation
from other nations
despite not being directly involved but
the government still needed arasaka due
to its massive influence on the japanese
economy
so the government nationalized all of
arasaka's assets
and arasaka became a japan-only company
for the next decade with the loss of its
ceo and power
an internal power struggle took place
within arusaka
there are three major players the first
was the kiji
led by hanako arasaka the youngest
daughter of saburo
hanako is an intelligent and
kind-hearted woman who wanted to live an
independent life rather than be a porn
in her father's corporate game
which is perhaps why she led a faction
to grab the power for herself
next there's the hatto led by mishiko
arasaka the youngest daughter of the
late k she is a u.s citizen and had the
backing of the u.s government
which wanted to take control of arasaka
the final group is the outside rebel
faction
taka led by yorenobu arasaka another of
saburo's children
yorenobu is by far the most interesting
of the three
when his father told him of the true
purpose of the arasaka corporation
yuronobu left his family in disgust he
went on to become a famous rocker boy
the johnny silverhand of japan more so
in the rebellious spirit as he was not
an actual musician
he started to steal dragons a gang he
used to attack arasaka from the shadows
yarinobu was even involved in the events
leading up to the nuclear destination of
arasaka tower
unfortunately there's not much
information on the details of this
decade-long family rivalry
however the conflict was eventually
solved and arasaka reunited under one
banner again
arasaka spent much of the next several
decades rebuilding power and regaining a
foothold outside of japan
a return to america was tricky following
its expulsion in 2023
but an opportunity presented itself for
arasaka to worm its way back in
the new united states had what was known
as the unification war in 2069
an attempt by the government to regain
control of a series of free states
that had seceded from the nation night
city had long been wary of the us
after it basically abandoned the city
following the night city holocaust
the city avoided involvement in the war
until the federal invasion of coronado
bay
gave them no choice but to act city
councilman lucius ryan turned to arasaka
for help
this was the opportunity arasaka was
looking for and it showed up
days later with the super carrier
causing a swift retreat
of the nusa the sudden involvement of
arasaka drummed up fears of another
fourth corporate war level crisis
and as such the new united states backed
down and signed a treaty of unification
ending the short-lived war night city
was now an independent city-state
and by the present day of 2077 arasaka
was once again
in control of the city which brings us
to the upcoming video game in which
arasaka plays a pretty major role
if you pick the kopo lifepath option
main character v will start as an
employee for arasaka's counter
intelligence division
and you'll get to see the ruthless
arasaka corporate lifestyle for yourself
the company is also involved in the
game's main plot
which involves stealing an ancient
prototype chip from arasaka
expect an appearance from saburo arasaka
himself
who is still ceo of the company at the
ripe old age of 158.
how could he possibly still be alive you
ask well let's just say saburo had plans
long ago to download his personality
into an ai when he died
the very existence of this piece of tech
has been at the heart of many of
cyberpunk's most important stories
and will be an important part of the
video game yorinobu will also play a
role in the story
he has for unknown reasons returned to
the fold of his father's empire
but knowing him he has his own plans and
motivations
the events of cyberpunk 2077 might end
up being another major chapter
in the history of arasaka we covered a
lot of information today and there are
plenty of details left for further
exploration
in fact next week jake will be diving
deeper into the fourth corporate war
so make sure to come back for that as
always let us know if there's a
particular subject in the world of
cyberpunk you want to know more about
and thanks for watching
[Music]
if you've been following cyberpunk 2077
you probably know how deadly
megacorporations like militech and
arasaka can be
not only can corporal conflicts be waged
economically but many regimes are
enforced through violence
theft and arson some of these conflicts
play out in smaller arenas a gunfight in
the streets of night city or an
assassination attempt on upper
management however if there's enough
resources at play these contained
conflicts can expand into full-blown
multi-court battles
this is what we call a corporate war
although there were three corporate wars
prior to the fourth
obviously the fourth corporate war
played a big part in shaping the
corporate
cultural and environmental landscape of
cyberpunk's universe
even though the war ended 50 years
before the events of cyberpunk 2077
remnants of the war are and always will
be present in night
city but before we dig into the fourth
corporate war let's take a look back at
the previous corporate wars
from 2004 to 2016 corporations were
involved in three distinct wars
most of these conflicts were fought by
security personnel and mercenaries with
high-tech weaponry
the first war was between epic games and
apple
i mean ebm and orbital air for control
over the remains of the failing company
transworld airlines ultimately orbital
air forced ebm to surrender and they
took control of transworld airlines
assets
although this war only lasted from 2004
to 2006 it set
a dangerous precedent for other
corporations it meant that violence and
warfare were viable tactics
many corporations beefed up their
security departments when the dust
settled
i say when the dust settled but the dust
from corporate warfare didn't have much
time to settle
in 2006 the second corporate war kicked
off
this time the major players were two
massive oil companies petrochem
and sovoil oil companies engaged in
deceit clandestine warfare and
underhanded tactics
that's the first time i've heard of
something like that while petrochem did
significant damage to stove oil it
ultimately lost the battle with sovoyle
coming out on top but the war
wreaked havoc on the world most notably
the southern pacific rim became a
cesspool of pollution and oil
according to cyberpunk 2020 firestorm
stormfront try saying that five times
fast
the south china sea became a lifeless
chemical stew all but inhabitable today
nations and economies were destroyed in
the fallout and sovoil was forced to pay
reparations the second corporate war was
also the first time a corporation
blatantly ignored governments and
nations in order to secure a victory
the third corporate war played out a
little differently than the last two due
to the fact that it was mostly fought on
the net this war was between investment
councillors meryl asukaga and finch and
the rothstein fund a subsidiary of the
bank of new york manf was embezzling
money from the rothstein fund when the
rothstein fund uncovered manf's scheme
they notified the los angeles district
attorney's office manf retaliated by
launching a netrunner assault on the
rothstein fund
a few months later manf left the corpses
of two rothstein execs on the da's
doorsteps
the rostein fund dissolved shortly after
the worst was yet to come for night city
in 2021
a german nautical tech company by the
name of in
inter international handles marine
act or ihag for short came into some
financial trouble
two competing nautical companies caught
wind of ihack's financial downturn and
both attempted to swoop in
and take control of the sinking pun
intended nautical corp
those companies were ocean technology
and energy corporation
otech for short and a french company i'm
not gonna try to pronounce
which we'll call cno for short ihag
otech and ceno had been ruthless
competitors for years
vying for economic dominance in marine
biotechnology when ihack filed for
bankruptcy
otec encino opened bids to acquire the
company unfortunately before a sino
negotiator could present a buyout
offered to ihag she was kidnapped i
wonder who
or what could have been behind that
wasting no time at all otec signed a
protection security contract with
militech a huge tech and weapons
corporation that had been in competition
with arasaka for years
of course this caused cino to partner up
with arasaka the japanese-based
mega-corporation
this more or less kicked off a proxy war
between militech and arasaka
officially both corpse are trying to
sway the outcome of the ihag takeover
unofficially the two major corporations
found a reason to launch a clandestine
conflict known as the shadow war
most of the attacks during this period
consisted of assassination
theft and net raids between arasaka and
militech the shadow raids didn't last
long though as the covert operations of
both companies came to a head
war broke loose known as the hot war
many corpse and security specialists
picked aside and fighting broke out in
all major cities worldwide at this point
the dispute between ceno and otec had
been resolved but the two massive
security corps were just getting started
this squabble was shaping up to be much
bigger than the corporate wars before it
both sides were escalating the conflict
every chance they got investing
heavily in weapons technology very few
parts of the world were off limits and
entire economies societies and cultures
suffered because of it
most notably in 2023 international trade
collapsed
the net also suffered from the conflict
it was rife with deadly programs and
dark areas thanks to militech and
arasaka's handiwork
netwatch the internet police couldn't
contain the virtual damage
either eventually the pre-fourth
corporate war net deteriorated and died
2023 was also the same year that johnny
silverhand and solo morgan blackhand
along with a group of anarchists
raided the arasaka building and night
city to destroy arasaka's secured
database for more info on this pivotal
event in johnny's life be sure to check
out our video on johnny silverhand
right after this this raid didn't quite
go as planned and a nuclear device was
set off destroying central night city
and killing three quarters of a million
people
it's unclear who detonated the nuke some
believe it was arasaka to protect
corporate secrets
while others believe it to be militech
finally the united states government
stepped in and nationalized militech
forcing arasaka out of the united states
with militech at her back
u.s president elizabeth kress used this
as an opportunity to take full control
of the government and reunify the united
states
of course the free state of northern
california was uninterested in
reunification
due to northern california's
disobedience crest did not aid night
city and its reconstruction efforts
and this brings us to the time of the
red but we'll save that for another
video
the fourth corporate war was a wake up
call for the world although governments
and nations still existed it became
apparent that corporations were calling
the shots
allegiances didn't lie in world leaders
or countries but in arasaka or militech
and of course i'm sure we'll see more of
this bitter rivalry between militech and
arasaka in cyberpunk 2077. thank you so
much for watching this episode of
cyberpunk lore
be sure to check back every saturday for
a new episode and if there's something
you'd like us to discuss
leave it in the comments below or you
can drop me a line on twitter
see you next time
[Music]
it's tough to talk about the world of
cyberpunk without spending some time on
one of the major security corporations
of the future
militech if you've been following
gamespot's cyberpunk lore series you've
probably heard us talk about the weapons
manufacturer often
you may know militech as arasaka's
number one competitor but the
corporation's history runs much deeper
than that
in 1998 the united states government
decided it was finally time to retire
the m16a2 assault rifle
marine corps officials were shipped a
handful of rifles to test out however
only three made it to the final trial
fn's sap
colts ar-17x and a firearm from a small
weapons firm called armatech lucey
international
the sap was a cheap unreliable firearm
its only saving grace apart from being
dirt cheap was that the parts and
ammunition were compatible with the nato
alliance armaments
the ar-17x was an excellent gun with a
big price tag
although it passed the field test with
flying colors the united states
ultimately didn't think it was worth the
price
the weapon from armatech lucey
international proved to be the best of
both worlds
it was reliable and moderately priced
united states marine corps general
donald lundy a name you'll want to
remember took
a liking to the armatech lucey firearm
it was his number one choice however due
to the financial collapse at the time
the government settled on the sap and
drafted up a contract with
fn lundy unhappy with the government's
decision warned officials that putting
the sap in the hands of soldiers could
be disastrous
it turned out lundy was right thousands
of soldiers armed with the clunky sap
rifles died in south and central america
to make matters worse the european
community kicked the sap to the curb in
favor of the fnral
a fantastic weapon that was incompatible
with fn's sap
frustrated lundy left the marine corps
to work with armatech lucey
international with his connections and
experience he was brought on as the
acting ceo while the founder antonio
lukesi focused on designing and creating
weapons thanks to lundy's connections to
the military he had no trouble securing
government contracts for armatech
lukkesi these contracts gave the small
arms company a leg up over the
competition as armatech lucasi
international expanded lundy and lucey
decided it was time to rebrand and so
militech was born militech's first big
break was to replace all the saps the
united states military bought only a few
years ago i'm sure lundy walked into the
pentagon that day with a big old i told
you so grin on his face
militech's ronin light assault rifle
replaced fn's sap
and with that militech's popularity
skyrocketed worldwide
as militech grew and grew it swallowed
up smaller security corporations
soon competitors of all shapes and sizes
were being dismantled and absorbed by
the monstrous corporation
of course the lucrative government
contracts weren't the only thing making
militech a fortune
many of their weapons were sold and
distributed to gang members mercenaries
everyday joes and security departments
at other companies
along with selling weapons and equipment
militech was known for hiring out their
private military to anyone or anything
with the money to pay for it this
includes but is not limited to
assassinations revolutions civil wars
and according to the cyberpunk 2077
world book ethnic cleansings yikes
by 2020 militech was the biggest weapons
company in the world
selling more firearms than any of their
competitors arasaka included however
money isn't everything and lundy knew
this
militech's influence in reach didn't
quite match the arasaka family and so
a not so friendly rivalry between
arasaka and militech came to be
the rivalry came to a head during the
fourth corporate war fighting between
arasaka and militech broke out all
around the world in nearly every major
country
if you'd like to know more about this
conflict check out our video on the
fourth corporate war
in the meantime here are some important
bits arasaka and militech aligned with
nautical tech companies vying for market
control early on arasaka and militech
launched a clandestine war against each
other known as the shadow war eventually
tensions bubbled over and the two
corporations kicked off a full-fledged
corporate-backed war
fighting persisted until a mysterious
pocket duke erupted in
our summer
foreign
foreign
okay
[Music]
hello and welcome to night city wire
episode
3 the show from us at cd projekt red
where we talk about
all things cyberpunk 2077
in today's episode we're gonna start by
taking you on a tour of night city
in a new gameplay video and have a chat
with senior level designer miles
then we're going to introduce you to the
gangs of night city in
another new gameplay video and have a
chat with mataysh from our quest team
then before we finish today's episode
we're going to give you a look at some
of the
incredible finalists in our pc case
modding contest
and we have some information that uh pc
players have been waiting to hear
so let's get started it's time to take
you on a tour of
night city
oh my god juanita here today's news is
novamax
hi there new tonight city
it's not so bad here how are we feeling
today
cause i feel amazing
the food the tie on 7th and haywood
the pierogies down by the docks a home
of pride and as always your business
is my business and this is
endless possibilities and endless lies
we are [ __ ] america and i don't know
how we're gonna fix it
the homeless population in night city
has risen by 300
[Music]
crime in night city is now double the
you're [ __ ]
well on that note that's it for today's
info flash sleep tight night city
the grass ain't greener anywhere else
night city what does it mean to you how
well do you know it's history
who was richard knight how many stations
are in the encart system
which city district boasts the best
burrito in town
the answers to these questions and more
can be found at the address at the
bottom of your screen
check it out and fall in love with night
city all over again
[Music]
well since night city is one of our
stars of this episode
there is actually quite a lot to talk
about so let's start at the beginning
how did night city come to be because
yes it exists in the world of the
tabletop
but uh how do you take that and make
what we've got now
well yeah as you can imagine making a
city that is as big
and complex as night city is is
quite the ambitious project first off we
sat down and we're really considering
what is it that we wanted to do with
night city in a way
night city is the style of cyberpunk
right it is one of its
main characters we wanted to make a city
that is very very believable right i
mean the word
immersion gets thrown around a lot but
really we wanted you to be able to dive
into it and feel like this is a real
place
and then secondly we also wanted to
provide enough variety between districts
so that exploring night city will always
be fun right there's no point
in making a city that is all sameish and
you know it doesn't really matter where
you go because
once you've been through one district
you feel like you've been through all of
them so for that
we first of started taking a look at the
real-life geography that night city is
located on and that would be
on the coast of california knowing that
night city would be
a coastal city gave us a bit of insight
into what we would
expect from the city layout you'd expect
the port
you'd expect huge industrial areas that
would facilitate this kind of trade that
you would assume a kind a city of this
type would have with the world
and then we went through and actually
divided the city
into several districts six of them and
some of them are based
on the original lore we decided to give
their own
characteristics in terms of architecture
their demographics the kind of people
that would live there
and also the function within the city
each of these districts in turn be
divided into further sub-districts which
we further characterized using the more
grand
theme of the larger district this
process
i think has resulted in a city that is
feels quite alive has a lot of character
where each district
feels like its own distinct zone without
feeling separated from the
larger picture and that results in
something that allows the player to
easily navigate
even the complex concrete jungles of
night city
simply by looking around and always
having a rough idea
where you actually are but night city is
clearly so
different from anything we've ever
created with the witcher can you give us
some idea about
or some insight into just how big and
like how densely packed
night city really is yes um so
i'm not exaggerating when i'm saying
that night city is easily the most
complex thing
that i or the others have worked on the
city
is super organic right it's not like a
chessboard layout
but the the layout of the city is crazy
and you can tell that it
grew in phases right where buildings
have been built on top of each other
and i guess the mega buildings that we
have showcased are a great example of
this
um you'll actually see that they are
located on
some kind of pillar you know and then
expand outside and then
up up high into the sky and underneath
it you'll have space for other buildings
this yields a lot of interesting
experiences when it comes to exploration
and that's the one thing i'm most
excited about for players to experience
we've been saying that our exploration
is super vertical
right but what this really means is that
it changes the way you explore the city
compared to our previous games you won't
be able to
easily set out on a target in the
distance right you won't be able to say
oh there's a castle on a hill over there
i'll try to get there and then you'll be
lost on the way
but here it's much more intimate much
more moment to moment you might be
roaming the cities and
um get a call by your fixer who informs
you about a job nearby that you might be
able to do right
or you find an alleyway and you walk
down one of the many many alleyways that
the city
has to offer and it's always a surprise
you don't know if you might stumble upon
some gangers hanging out that are up to
no good sometimes
and these are the moments that i often
get surprised with you even stumble upon
the odd elevator that is meant to
connect parts of the
you know different layers of the city
and it's quite astonishing sometimes to
see
where you come out when you enter one of
these and you know find that oh this is
actually how it connects to the world
that's crazy and now i'm here
now i know there's a shortcut that i can
take
and again this all serves to
really enhance this sense of wonder that
we all come to love from open world
games and the whole city is built to
cater to that
i mean you guys have really brought
night city to life and i really want to
make a point of that it is a living
breathing city
so as a level designer can you give us
some insight into those little touches
that you guys have made because
i hear you guys have even been placing
rubbish by hand
oh yes we've been placing quite a bit of
rubbish and that's certainly one of the
more glorious parts of being a level
designer or an environment artist where
you get to litter
the streets that you've spent time
building with the garbage but it's
details such as this that
we find really important to make the
city feel alive and also
we take great pride in the process of
making this right
we have a lot of fun actually placing
all of what we call
mini stories right these are little
encounters
and that you can find when you simply
walk
along the streets of course we have huge
quests right
side quests we have lots of side
activities that you can do
but it always is nice to just kind of
stop down for a minute and take a look
at your surroundings
and that we have so lovingly created and
try to see if there maybe isn't
something that you can be a little
detective for
now one other thing that i think is
really really cool is also the fact that
we have
um actually named every single street in
the city
so not only will npcs be able to
communicate their
locations or the locations they want you
to visit by sort of referring to the
street names
but also you will be able to talk to
your friends about it in that way right
have you been to
poplar street in japan town for example
um
and i think this is a small detail but
the philosophy that we have with these
kind of things
is that you know many many small things
contribute to the sum of it
which is hopefully then you being able
to explore a city that you feel is truly
alive
and that you haven't been experiencing
before
uh well miles thank you so much for
giving us your insight i suppose when
the game launches you could be an
official night city tour guide instead
right
i might be yeah you know if this game
death thing doesn't work out for me i
might
might retire and become a tour guide in
night city
don't forget that if you are tuning in
late or if you just
want to watch anything again we will be
uploading everything to our channels
soon now from the 6th street to the
valentinos it's time to introduce you to
the
gangs of night city
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how things work in night city
stronger survive but that's how things
stand
you're either somebody where you fizzle
out into nothing
then see in a city that lets you get by
without buddies
be very careful my friend we are all so
far from home
which gang's the city's biggest and
baddest according to the ncpd
scavs hold the body count title or
maelstrom depending on the season
one time a maelstrom ganger killed a
young kid right in front of my eyes
for shits and giggles sucking psychos
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
and can't be i'm gonna
introduce you to our meat grinder
about time we had some fun big belts
shall never forget
never i hate these borg [ __ ]
she's a gang like any other right i'll
take the valentinos
they follow god and the santa madre
honor means something to him
how'd you meet jackie we started out
together in the valentinos
no in the [ __ ] bible book club i
gotta give style points to the
valentinos
they have a punishment for every
occasion
quick shout out to everyone in haywood
and santo domingo lately the valentinos
and sixth street have had a bigger bone
to pick
sixth street why'd they want to wipe you
can't
i've dealt with sixth street before we
do the run they'll transfer the cred
come on let's go before sixth street
shows up
shot shot shot any more second amendment
fans in the house huh
hate those bastards vomit lofty
patriotic [ __ ] all day
time to bring on the future any idea how
many attacks from behind the black wall
we neutralize
if the voodoo boys breach the black wall
we'll all be [ __ ]
voodoo boys urban myth i thought
just net runners spooking each other no
such gang you know i heard a few things
about you
voodoo boys best runners in town you do
not steal from the voodoo boys
i see you always for them pacifica's
just haiti 2.0 their own island
cut off from the rest of the city this
is our turf
our home until last week the animals
crawled in
animals are the craziest [ __ ] gang in
the city
[Music]
animals aren't the play here are they
they're hired muscles someone else
needed them
i [ __ ] you over you [ __ ] the gang
over somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the corp see how this
works now
[Music]
my husband's new westbrook very high in
the tiger claws
they did what made the best eddies sold
sex and black market
see a lot of tigers they run this place
know what else they do well
break the needs of people who ask
questions we gotta do something shut the
[ __ ] up the tigers will kill us
come on baby tiger claws killed one girl
too many
so people took matters into their own
hands
spoke with ballistic girls pimps
outcasts the whole freak show it's how
the mocs got started
us have each other's backs we look out
for one another
you're looking for some company tonight
how'd you hook up with the mocks
i thought suzy and the gang could really
change something in this city
moxes and nomads don't seem so different
both seem to yammer a lot about
community
solidarity tell me about the badlands
not much going on out here oh contraire
this is an ecosystem nomads grafton shiv
corporations and drifters they form a
complete hole
remove one part the delicate balance
topples
here in the aldocaldos it all stays in
the family
classic dilemma what comes first family
or the outside world
this family will go to hell and back
everyone in this city lives in their own
bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
quicksand
[Music]
matajus thank you so much for joining us
i have personally been really excited to
give people a closer look at the gangs
we've shown a little bit on twitter but
their styles are so distinct
yes i enjoyed them a lot as well in our
game i think they're very cool
but let's start them with the kind of
role that they play because gangs really
do play a prominent role in night city
correct
yes definitely the gangs they rule the
streets of night city you know they have
the newest cyberware they have the
newest weaponry and they are
really a power that everyone needs to
take into account when they are
thinking of operating in night city you
will encounter them as you explore the
city of course but also as you complete
main quests side quests different jobs
for the fixers
sometimes you might even get hired by
them but then
i suppose everybody's thinking then can
you join again
well v is a merc and mercs of night city
are this unique distinct group
that stick mostly to themselves right
and they get jobs from
variety of factions they can get jobs
from corporations they can get jobs
from gangs they can get job from
different kind of like influential
clients
because of this nobody will ever trust a
merc
to be one of them right and the gangs
are no exception here they are looking
only for like people that they know will
be loyal to them right and that they
will fight for their cause
all of the time not just some of the
times when it's profitable to them
so because of this we will mostly stick
to the afterlife and the after
our life are this group of mercs this
legendary group of mercenaries in night
city
they get the best jobs they get the most
money the best clients and so on so if
you want to become
a legend in night city you are going to
the afterlife
so we've obviously mentioned distinct
style then so does that mean there are
kind of special gang themed weapons and
items and clothing for players to
find and use yes definitely there are
different vehicles that you can drive
for example there are cars there are
motorbikes
then of course there are different
pieces of clothing
uh themed after gangs there are weapons
and so on so yeah definitely there are
things to look forward to
i suppose there's somebody who's spent
as much time as you have
kind of getting to know the gangs i have
to ask which is your favorite and why
so i would have to say probably
maelstrom
simply because they have this unique
distinct feel
and this weird aesthetic about them so
the idea about maelstrom is
they are people who want to cross the
boundary between
the machine and human right they are
changing so much of their body with
cyberware that they
no longer look human really on top of
that they are also very unpredictable
it's very difficult to say what they
will do
at any point when you meet them at one
moment they can be shaking hands with
you and at the other moment
you know they will pull gano gun out on
you and they bring in this element of
chaos into the game which i
really enjoy personally oh matty thank
you so much for joining us
it's always interesting to learn what uh
your favorite gang is i think it kind of
tells me a little bit about you
oh does it what does it say about me
well we'll talk about that later but for
now before we wrap
up today's episode we asked people
to show us their creativity and design a
pc
case mod cyberpunk style our panel of
judges selected
five finalists and we teamed them up
with professional case models
to bring their concept to reality
[Music]
these five amazing designs will be
fighting for the main prize an alienware
aurora pc
along with other awesome gaming
peripherals brought to you by our
partners
alienware nvidia and steelseries
let's see the mods
and numbers i absolutely love this one
the whole aesthetic works with each
other
absolutely next level honestly kind of
terrifying
exactly the type of thing i would expect
to find at a trade show
it really looks like it could have come
straight out of the game
[Music]
to watch the full pc case modding video
and to get more information about when
the winning design will be available on
charity auction
stay tuned to our social media channels
looking at those pc case mods it reminds
me that we do have
one more thing to reveal if you're going
to be playing cyberpunk 2077
on pc when it launches this november we
do have some specs to share that i think
some of you have been waiting for the
minimum system requirements for
cyberpunk
are a windows 7 or 10 pc an intel core
i5 3570k or amd
fx8310 eight gigs of ram
and an nvidia geforce gtx 780
or an amd radeon rx 470
in the storage department the game will
take up roughly 70 gigs of space
and although it will run off a hdd we do
recommend an ssd
as for the recommended specs you're in
the green if you're rocking windows 10
an intel core i7 4790
or amd ryzen 3 3200g
12 gigs of ram and an nvidia geforce
gtx 1060 or amd radeon
r9 fury thank you so much for joining us
for episode three of night city wire
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels shortly
and we will be back soon with episode 4.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you